Das Jodeln – eine Tradition aus den Alpen.
Doch ist es deshalb altmodisch?
Das sieht hier niemand so – beim
“OU Jodelfest” in Gonten in der Schweiz.
Des is a Lebensfreude – wenn so … wenn so
a Tag dann auf einmal Lebensfreud‘ hat,
dann kannst du‘s einmal raus da lassen.
In Workshops kommen Anfänger
und Fortgeschrittene zusammen –
darunter auch einige jüngere Teilnehmer.
Weil es cool ist. Es ist zeitlos.
Also wenn etwas richtig gut ist, dann ist es
nicht ans Alter gebunden, finde ich.
Ich glaub, wenn man Freude hat an der
Stimme, dann kommt es nicht drauf an,
ob es für die Alten oder die Jungen gemacht
ist. Ich glaub Musik ist für alle gemacht.
Gerade erlebt der alpine Gesang
ein Comeback -
zum Beispiel in modernen Interpretationen:
Beim Eurovision Song Contest 2017
schafft es dieser Mix aus Jodeln,
Rap und Pop
aus Rumänien
immerhin auf den siebten Platz.
Ein viraler Hit: “Ma Chérie”
des Schweizers DJ Antoine
in der Jodel-Version als Werbung für den
Kanton Wallis.
Jodeln kann man heute auch
mit einer App erlernen.
Oder sogar an der Universität:
Seit knapp einem Jahr kann man an der
Hochschule Luzern Jodeln studieren –
im Studiengang Volksmusik.
Doch Jodeln ist gar nicht so einfach.
Typisch sind die schnellen Wechsel zwischen
tiefer Brust- und hoher Kopfstimme –
auch beim „Dudler“,
der Wiener Form des Jodelns.
Das Besondere hier:
Der „Dudler“ ist keine reine Vokalmusik,
sondern wird von Instrumenten begleitet.
Jodeln ist vor allem auch ein
Gemeinschaftserlebnis.
… gibt‘s auch unheimlich Energie.
Also ich merk das immer wenn wir … wenn
wir wirklich hier auf Jodel-Festivals sind –
man kann fast nicht einschlafen,
weil man so … weil man so energetisiert ist.
Das Jodeln soll als Kommunikationsform in
den Bergen entstanden sein,
durch Rufe von einer Alm zur anderen.
Heute wird eher zum Spaß gejodelt –
so wird die Tradition in die Gegenwart geholt,
zum Beispiel über Improvisation.
Ich kann natürlich reden und dann irgendwie
…
Der Musiker Markus Prieth organisiert das
Jodelfest und beobachtet,
dass immer mehr Menschen
das Jodeln für sich entdecken.
Die Leute suchen vielleicht
auch wieder was Eigenes.
Man hört in Kursen immer so wieder:
Ja, ich will an meine Wurzeln.
Aber jeder hat seine eigene Geschichte,
wie er dazu kommt: manche über die Stimme,
manche über
die eigene musikalische Geschichte
und da entdecken sie halt im Jodeln,
weil es keine Sprache hat,
keine Wortbedeutungen in diesem Sinne,
weil es auch eine Herausforderung darstellt,
weil auch das Klischee einen Reiz darstellt.
Jodeln ist also längst mehr als der einst so
belächelte Alpengesang –
auch außerhalb der Berge.
Im nächsten Jahr zieht das “OU Jodelfest”
zum ersten Mal in die Großstadt: nach Berlin.